well a lack of school bus drivers is
really putting a damper on fall sports
for nearly two months families have been
reaching out to us saying their students
bussers are showing up really late kate
houston joins us now to break down how
transportation is impacting students
both in and outside of the classroom
kate
yes there are nearly 240 bus driver
vacancies within the school district
normally drivers are recruited during
the summer but the district says that
they weren't able to do that due to the
pandemic but after delays and changes to
athletic schedules parents want concrete
solutions
ccsd is supposed to care i don't see
that happening i see excuses
chad dobar's son plays tennis at
centennial high school they received
this letter stating non-conference
matches would be canceled and some
practices would be moved to the weekend
as a parent it's frustrating because now
instead of having you know weekdays to
go see our children play now we have to
give up an extra day when a lot of us
work and we like our free time dobar
says this should have been dealt with
months ago we'll have to bite the bullet
improvise adapt to overcome
not a problem but
the school district missed the bus on
this one during a q a last week the
district said they would begin using
charter buses for weekday sports this
would retain about 45 drivers for school
routes there's 30 40 50 minute delays
however parents like tiffany wooten say
they're still having problems i work my
husband works so
being told well then pick up your kid
drop them off well what about my my
bills wooten is now receiving letters
due to absences and tardies while the
district says that can be fixed wooden
is concerned about a loss in learning
they would want the same for their kids
it's time that they start answering us
give us logical answers
the school district has condensed 25 bus
routes to help with delays at this time
they're working on some incentives and
other options which need to be bargained
with unions ccsd is actively hiring
though for bus drivers wages range from
around 15 dollars an hour to 20 dollars
an hour back to you brian